je demande des excuses et monstres
aujourd'hui sur crazy taxi un autre
merveilleux jeu de ce jeu 1,80 donc
c'est une casse n'a franchement c'est un
jeu qui coûte 20 euros et que je trouve
génial parce qu'on retrouve également
des bons vieux jeux bref ces partis
crazy taxi pour qu elles pour ceux qui
se souviennent sorti sur ps2 gamecube et
enfin il est ressorti sur ps2 gamecube
en tout cas moi j'y avais joué sur
gamecube il me semble bref touche start
c'est parti on se comprend au filet où
il y va sauver des gens dans la rue
jouer au jeu arcade original crazy box
free corde
original ce qu'on ait des gens riches et
noah et cette blague n'était pas
original ah ah ah bon c'est quoi les
touches c'est sûrement pas ce à quoi bon
comment max et emme salut y aller cela
l'a alors là je crois qu'elle monte est
clair vous suivent la flèche et je crois
si on fait des trucs de ouf et tous à
nous donne de l'argent où on est sûr de
ses boîtes de flacq si je sens des
allées on continue on va tout coin
pardon au temps pour moi non monnier
madame ollier on passe sous l'eau
comment ça on peut aller sous l'eau
ils sont serrés la times up j'ai rien
compris aux jeunes voilà donc c'était
une course à 0 $ donc on part pour être
milliardaire actuellement c'est plutôt
bien c'est cool super ouais ça ça veut
dire qu'on a gagné je crois crazy box
les 234 1 après 785 oui je me sens bien
il a un gros nez il a le flair pour les
bons clients
vous avez compris la blague non c'est
pas en éclats tous les vols dans la
limite de temps oui où sont les chapeaux
bien pour nous ou accélère thiès pas à
nous
est-ce qu'on va perdre oui je pense pour
sauter par dessus un pont fail ce qu'on
m'explique comment je dois faire et
comment je peux y arriver
c'est ma voiture n'est ne va pas
attendez il ya juste à rester appuyé sur
l'accélérateur alors le gameplay plus
bas sur du monde
131 je peux pas faire plus ou alors il
ya de la nitro et je sais pas c'est quoi
la touche à la lll et hop au milieu des
parasols toi t'es un mec tu prends un
taxi pour le boire un coca du maître
c'est pas grave ça se voit avec tambour
les à toi
non je te louper el houdoud vous faire
vous je veux ma liberté
j'irai dans ce mr j'ai pris mon envol
pour parce qu'il faut fermer mais on va
attendre
yes on va prendre la fille elle va nous
elle va nous porter chance
elle a des mains de bonhomme sucré fait
cent plus un jeu les prix ont regardé
regardez là comme elle touche les fesses
peintes à elle et des sondes ce jeu ils
sont dingues
alors en fait cédé client qui paie pour
avoir des frayeurs ce quand même géniaux
c'est vraiment génial comme clients or
mon dieu c'est pas mort on passe sous
l'eau on est jeune comme sa petite
visite soumaré il n'y a pas de 6 et
quand je m'en bats les couilles de la
course regardez un homme qu'il ya des
gens qui se baignent dans joue au yoyo
fucking serious cela au doute uteq ma
portière mon gars parce que génial c'est
que on peut faire absolument tout dans
le jeu
c'est via un voile il n'y a pas de
soucis voilant passion des rails il ya
aucun souci mais y'a aucun souci
apparemment il est plutôt pressé là on
peut passer les murs comme ça yahia le
mono clip en fait activé tout le temps
c'est vraiment un jeu un jeu génial moi
j'adore ce jeu donc ils sont un millier
de voitures mais ils veulent prendre un
taxi quand même tu vas chez la police
jackson ou rebelle et pendant anako leur
coach et tout le bordel c'est parti bête
je dois rejoindre top
là on a un petit coeur non moi je prends
le client sous l'eau même si on n'aura
pas le temps autant prendre un client
qui est sous l'eau merde il attend
depuis longtemps personne ne veut de lui
ça va quoi [ __ ] merde il a dû trouver
un taxi sous marin avant moi
oh je suis déçu voilà depuis son fils
soit on finit sous l'eau et non est-ce
que c'est par la merde je me suis fait
avoir c'est un piège c'est le jeu qui
peut donner l'âge à 22 secondes aussi
celui de faire ça par contre s'ils
donnent que 1 $ par sauce je suis pas
très d'accord avec ces tarifs là ça sera
bien plus cher en prime de risque
évidemment c'est ce jeu faut il joue
avec une guitare dans les magasins
guitare à part dont il va on y va on y
attend pas de panique madame tu vas me
filer mes sous c'est moi qui tu le dis
ah merde et voilà bad d'accord alors on
va tout de suite visité le cas de cette
dame
oh là là on y va comme ça ja oui c'est
chaud c'est la vase et saute dans l'eau
toi tu fais de la plongée toi y avait
notre post punk on aurait pu prendre le
puck
mais d'abord [ __ ] le tuent d'autres sa
mère dans la poissons de merde
craig simon
mais sont-ils au maire